off by Morris mix it out for Yanis makes  the move those strong off the glass he's  so long prior to that the Wizards have  launched at this team here since  December of 2013  tip pumping in it was fantastic gotta go  back to those wall comes over to try to  get a steal  that leaves Dellavedova and now garage  it they go back to be honest  Brogdon for an open three and it buries  it even the new continuation rules and  play and I actually like that the back  down under the dish  [Music]  [Applause]  that's a Euro step 1/2 score the field  goal his third personal months ago at 11  ties and 11 lead changes in this game  that had Coco packing in no call he  shoots and scores  let's so drive gets past wall missed it  and followed by kind of compost  this afternoon's game to secure it  because they're going to lose it anyway  after 28 second say that I get you some  extra tickets be honest it's exactly  what